bitterroot the first is a quality
management standard in the city hall of
beauty i asked what was the new new
quality in the whole Ukraine when we
think about the Polish non-governmental
sector about this more than 40,000 and
Joseph we have to remember about the
history 25 years ago the poles were
world champions on strikes and again
printings protests and about 15 years
ago many of us understood that our
skills soon we'll be totally unuseful
that when soviet army will leave the
poland our skills to be against will be
totally unuseful that we have to learn
how to be responsible and i would say
that majority of the programs Oh which
links polish and Ukrainian partners
about how to take responsibility for the
local community for the life around in
the local community for the life in the
town in the region oh we have quite a
lot of programs which concern not only
makinami coliforms local democracy
regional government independent media
human rights but also education science
culture and in last few years the
consequences of integration of Poland
into European Union few examples as I
mentioned is a certificate in beer games
oh the project clean you can clean clean
earth our earth foundation from Poland
in the cooperation with association of
ukrainian city
started the project that citizens that
students that you try to take her about
the situation ecology in the communities
in the first year 75,000 volunteers were
involved in the second year without any
external money 320,000 people were
involved or in workshops in seminars
address to the teachers school
administrators several thousands of
students headmasters participate in live
in cooperation with the local in-service
training center are that special program
for teachers about participatory methods
of teaching was started Association of
educators introduced the program of
measuring the quality of the student
performance in Ukraine educational
system in last few years two or three
more and more NGOs on both sides start
to think about the question which are
linked with established the Polish
border as the Schengen border
introducing the visa regime between
Poland and Ukraine the first important
project was started in 2001 it was about
monitoring borders and these are
procedures the Polish non-governmental
organization started to monitor the
behaviors of Polish border officers of
custom officers and today they are
monitoring the procedures in the polish
consulate in all the neighbor country
then in last year in the year of the
decision of polish decision of joining
European Union several programs about
the European future of Ukraine Muslim
youth parliament in jamish polish Albert
Sherman Foundation started to establish
a network of / Ukrainian student clubs
education for democracy foundation the
cooperation with newspaper Vaisakhi
zamak started to share with Ukraine the
experience of the European